[Music]
welcome back to the gym julien podcast
he looks very confused this episode is
brought to you by post mates guys you
don't do at the store post mates will go
to the store for you you have to go the
restaurant post me it's a restaurant for
you ok it is the delivery app 24 hours a
day 365 days a year they'll deliver
whatever you need from the store a
restaurant near you post means giving
you $100 a free delivery credit for the
first 7 days using code Jen and Julie
when you download the app we only use it
every day check it out post mates also
guys farmers dog-hole amazing real
ingredients given to your dogs in their
dog food is what they want we've been
feeding our dogs farmers dog food for a
long time no official diet of Sam it's
official diet of these little guys human
grade food and recipes that are board
certified by board certified veterinary
nutritionists they approve it ok so you
know what's good go do the farmers
dog.com / Angelina get 50% off your
first two weeks of doggy food they still
go freakin nuts for it it's me Anna day
we've been feeding them farmers are for
everyone they still go nuts for you so
get like something else that was fresh
made like that yeah and they would keep
tired of it it was like yeah you're so
rude I just like in farmers dog - you
don't have to like to frost it you can
put it in the fridge and defrost it so
much easier
yeah the other time we used to have to
like put in the microwave and like oh
man it was a production and just turn
their nose up at it and like [ __ ] off I
know I couldn't believe when they
started get snotty about that [ __ ] off
right mobile did you see speaking
opposed mates also do see post malloon
tried to post me $11,000 night-vision
goggles the other day I did see that why
was my first question was aware where
are we supposed to
I don't know like a Dick's Sporting
Goods or something yeah he's just like
hope this works and then the company saw
and they just sent it to him for free
but that's sometimes really funny post
Malone can only do post them alone
things you talked about on your radio
felt really great
no well so we have a game that we're
gonna play in a little bit right marble
you'll play a game look at him sitting
on a hard surface no he's sitting his
butt is on the hard surface no I have
been working with him to try and
continue to get I know I've seen I've
seen I've watched around the house also
forgive my sick voice I kind of came
down with a random cold yesterday so I'm
still dealing with that but I'm better
yeah I don't know what happened you just
woke up and you were like violently ill
I think I err I was fine you were fine
and I also what the weirdest part was I
didn't feel it coming normally when I
get sick I had the night before I'm like
oh yeah yeah here we go yeah you get the
tingle in your throat and you're like
[ __ ] but it was nothing I felt fine I
woke up completely sick for I got
nothing and I still feel nothing well
stay away from me just don't even look
at me I think we're just friends
we're just I wanted to take some time to
talk about last minute trips and lobstah
chol on the podcast because I feel like
this is a platform that I can just kind
of like freely speak to you guys I was
thinking about being a video on it I was
thing about being a Twitter post and I
think this is kind of the best way to do
it because I could just like talk and
explain the situation and you know where
I'm at with with everything um so a lot
of you been asking when's the next
episode of last minute trips and what's
happening with my obstacle it's been
pretty quiet on that end of things so I
understand the the curiosity and I
wanted to let you know that after a lot
of thought and 2 years of doing the show
I I've made the decision to end last
minute trips and step away from the show
entirely in sort of a long story short
answer to why is I feel like we
accomplished what we wanted to
accomplish with the show or at least I
accomplished what I set out to
accomplish and I'll touch back on that
but first I just
I want to give this massive huge huge
thank you to the supporters of
last-minute trips you guys have been so
incredibly passionate in supporting the
show way beyond any of my expectations
of anyone supporting anything I do
something about last-minute trips really
struck a chord with a lot of you guys
and it was just one of the most
rewarding experiences to make a show
where we traveled to the small towns we
did and and just have the response that
that we constantly got where people were
proud to show us their little town or
wait in the airport's for us or take
last-minute trips of their own and take
pictures and send them to us and just
the whole thing felt felt so contagious
with with like the positive energy that
you guys felt from the show so I'm
forever grateful for that you guys have
made it such a rewarding two years of
creating and traveling and something I
never expected to happen so first and
foremost thank you to all of the
supporters for last-minute trips
secondly I want to thank Colin for for
taking this ride with me
it's it's a crazy crazy ride that I've
taken with Colin and we have a bond a
lot of people don't really ever get to
have that sort of bond having
experienced what we experienced and
traveled how we've traveled and just the
time we've spent in bizarre situations
while filming the show great wonderful
less than wonderful knowing the whole
spectrum of of what last-minute trips
gave to us we had a lot of a lot of
times together a lot of good times a lot
of tough times but I'll forever look
back on last-minute trips and have fond
memories of it with Colin so thank you
to Colin for for doing it with me and
making it possible so in two years of
doing the show
I've been really close to it kind of
looking at it with a microscope and I
kind of feel like that's that's how I
needed to be to get it get it to where I
wanted it to be to make little
improvements and get things right
logistically and creatively just every
single episode just looking at it so
close and I think sometimes when you're
that close and intimate with something
it really takes you stepping back and
looking at it from kind of a more
general big picture sense of things and
asking yourself why you're doing it and
I was able to do that and and my
reaction is I'm so proud of the show but
I think we'd done it I think we did it
two years ago we had this idea that we
wanted to start a series where we
documented truly spontaneous travel and
I think we did it and I'm proud of it
and I think we accomplished more
importantly I think I accomplished what
I set out to do with this show and I
think it's time to move on to the next
thing and I think it's a tough decision
to make because like anything you know
that's good or something that you find
pleasure in or get rewarded with it's
tough to let that go or to move on to
the next thing but I think ultimately
the show it stands strongly by itself
the way it is and I don't feel like
creatively we need to keep doing it on a
more real life sense of things
last-minute trips is hella
time-consuming what you guys see is a 15
to 25 minute episode of us traveling
over the weekend but behind the scenes
it's a week before that of
pre-production and then you have the
weekend of filming on on the location
and traveling and then you have a full
week after that of editing and posting
so that comes down to over 50% of a
month being dedicated to an episode of
last minute trips and wow I'm so glad
that I decided to designate all my time
that I had to what we've created so far
I just I can't swing it anymore
and I say
with all the stuff I have going on in my
life a lot of you guys are very familiar
with my life with the twitch stream and
being with Jenna on her videos and
making my videos and the podcast my
family and friends my hobbies all the
things that I don't document on a
day-to-day basis I just felt like
amongst other things I was spreading
myself pretty thin and having genuinely
sat down with myself and asking myself
the question why am I still doing it I
think I came to the conclusion that I'm
proud to leave it where it is so thanks
again to everyone who took the ride with
us I hope at some point I'll create
something else that generates one-tenth
the amount of passion that you guys
showed for last minute trips because it
was truly a very very rewarding
experience and like I said I have only
fond memories looking back on my
experiences with the show so that's it
well I know that that was a hard
decision to come to it's not like an
easy thing that you made overnight nor
Colin and I'm proud of you because it's
always really difficult to end something
that you've invested a lot of time and
energy and effort into but to recognize
when your life is changing or your
circumstances are changing or your
feelings about the project are changing
or anything and to end something is
always very bittersweet but I'm proud of
you for making a decision and deciding
to move forward in the future with
something else you know yeah thank you
and I didn't include it in that little
spiel but biggest thank you in the world
to jennifer supporting this project
while it lasted and sucking it up all
the weekends I would leave and all the
weeks I would hide myself into a closet
okay I know when you say it like it was
you know half a month for every LMT it's
really true and I would just say goodbye
to you basically like the week before I
would say goodbye to use your like
visitor yeah you're you're physically
mentally emotionally not here and then
the weekend you're physically gone and
also incredibly busy and those hours are
insane you guys are waking up at the
crack of dawn
and doing that and filming all day and
then you know doing it for three or four
days in a row which is fine you can push
through that but then the real struggle
begins about editing week that turned
our own time of having the complete
episode finished by Friday yeah and I
would just say goodbye to Julian all
week just say goodbye to him you know
and it's it's hard I know it's hard on
me is hard on Rome yeah and we would
sort of just like say goodbye to you
guys you but you know you and Rome you
were both incredibly supportive and I
just want to specifically thank you guys
you know waiting for for letting us yeah
the easy end of the deal I had three
dogs to watch Rome had two dogs and
toddlers Rome
and I feel like a question that is
probably gonna come at me after this is
what's happening with lobster go and I
think just kind of the easy answer is
early on week we created wife Scott me
and Colin as like hard dual company with
his goal of like making in a production
company with this vision in mind where
we could shoot production stuff and we
could vlog it while we did is kind of a
unique thing and it very quickly just
became last-minute trips like wob school
equals last-minute trips and I think
most people know that you know there was
a one-off thing we did here and there
but for the most part that defined wofe
circle so that last-minute trips in my
obstacle both are be putting are being
put to an end at this point and again
like you know I I wish Colin the
absolute best he's living in Austin
Texas now and he's he's out there doing
his thing he's directing music videos
he's got his podcast and I I know he's
gonna create great stuff and I and I
encourage all of you guys to wish him
the best as well and thank you again for
taking the the journey with me but yeah
to kind of get ahead the answer is
obstacle equals last-minute trips and
both of them are coming to an end so
that is it and I hope I've answered the
questions that you guys have had and
asked me for a while now I'm ready to
move on and create something cool again
and on to the next thing in the most you
know positive and thankful grateful way
possible well you'll you'll need to just
explore what you
like doing because I know that that
creating that show itched
a scratch that you had to you know film
things that were pretty that aren't a
vlog necessarily or you know yeah use
your drone get some cool shots of things
that you don't usually see and I know
personally when you guys first started
the show there was that part of you that
was just dying to travel the country and
that that was a really cool thing I feel
like everybody at some point has that
itch to just like I can't wait to get
out to other places that aren't my
backyard to go and film or hang out and
explore find myself whatever it is and
then as time goes by that definitely
starts to take a toll on you you know
and it's just a lot like the travel
aspect of it is a ton and I can only
hope for you that you find something
that fulfills you creatively as that
project did without some of the you know
traveling that was so awful not awful
but like it's time-consuming it's a lot
you know yeah I hope that you can find
something that fulfills you creatively
that's not quite as time-consuming I
guess yeah you know ideally that would
that would be the case yeah yeah you
[ __ ] sleeping cold boats on trailers
and man I'll just say one thing is like
I have a lot of memories from that show
that I never thought I would have in my
life
of doing things I've had a lot of times
of you calling me being like we there's
no food there's nothing and I'm just
like begging Julian to pack something
for the airplane and he's like no I'll
be fine I'll get some food the airport
like a celiac vegan going into places of
the country where all you can eat are
french fries which is fine but like I
don't know if you've ever eaten french
fries four days in a row because I
certainly have started just feeling so
bad like just so bad yeah I always have
that like when I'm on the road and
there's nothing like we're traveling
fries and wine is always like a good and
it's great for like - good night
no like a night it's
and then the next day it's not mine I'm
not okay
if you want to take a last minute trip
and then end up in a trailer park in the
middle of nowhere just and you're vegan
just chips or your friend okay that's
all set just a baked potato over an open
flame five minutes though yeah Colin
Colin told me that I was gonna work and
I still tried it I like stabbed a potato
with the stick and I held it over an
open flame and I tried to take a bite
after and he made me spit it out cuz he
says apparently can get sick from eating
raw potato I guess I don't know but
anyway thank you and thank you for
allowing me to talk about it on the
podcast I think there there's every once
in a while some things happen in your
life that you just want to sit and talk
about and clear the air and kind of
explain things to you so I think that is
also one of the great things about the
podcast yeah another great thing about
the podcast is playing games which we
have one here we've only played twice
before only twice
you guys always request this though yeah
I was looking through our old episodes
and looking into the comments of them
and you guys really want us to not even
get started on more things to rant about
so good and bad though good and bad so
we created a list actually with the help
of you guys we what I've been doing when
I need suggestions for the podcast is
I've been going on our Instagram at
Jenna Julian and I've been doing the
little pull for the question function
where you can submit your answers
anonymously and I can read all of them
so you guys helped make all of these
happen so thank you for that so we're
gonna each take a turn pulling out of
the cup something that we can't even get
started about don't even get me started
and get me started and we also we also
said at one point right like we can we
can not steal but we can gift one of
them I like this deal like a steal
function okay so basically if I pick
something that Jenna really wants to
rants about she can steal it once and I
can do the same but otherwise you're
forced to rant about whatever's you have
to rant about it and it can be a
positive rant or a negative rants right
like you can some of them can go either
way who pulls it you wanna go first
I'm not looking I hate how you don't
fold these I hate it
oh don't even get me started
oh my virgos are better than Aries Wow I
didn't get that one I mean just off the
top these are facts like this isn't even
an opinion at all virgos are better than
Aries basically every sign in the zodiac
is better than Aries this could say for
[ __ ] anything and it's still true
still effects forget do I get to argue
back you can if you want okay go on
Jillian you are a tornado Aries are wild
there's literally jokes on the internet
about people holding their babies while
they're giving birth so that they don't
have in Aries because have you met an
Aries you all have [ __ ] wild with we
provide energy that no one else knows
how to provide oh my god it's like
starting things and never finishing them
a bunch of energy moving in one
direction that that is just like it's
like it's like a tree branch it's
forever growing out and then just like a
little shoot this way a little shoot
this way a little shoot this way a
little shoot this way always going in
one [ __ ] direction just never like
actually growing a nice thick lush tree
of careful plant energy it's just like
forever forwards
so I'm healthy and I'm growing oh my god
right
no and I'm providing you're stubborn
you're a tornado of energy I'm not that
stubborn you're kind of stubborn you're
more sever than I am but when I'm right
yeah you're more because I'm right
you're way more stubborn than me when
I'm right
always that's not true okay all right
90% of the time guess I don't argue
about something unless I'm right okay
fine
but how about this right say we're in a
time crunch if we need to do something
fast I'm not gonna tell Jenna to do it
I'm gonna do it cuz I know that I can
make it happen fast
you told me you can make anything happen
fast but I'll at least make sure it gets
done
sometimes you sacrifice quality
constantly sometimes it's better to be
quick than no no that's not true so much
of like just life is better to like make
sure you get it done right one time then
bad fast seven times but having having
in your brain that you need to organize
plan every little thing in your life yes
that is paralyzing sometimes it's not
it's absolutely no for dogs
it's good for children it's good for
people people respond well to structure
and schedules and planning and
understanding it's some meals a sense of
peace sometimes in and and like routine
in order to have that but you need a
little bit of craziness thrown no you do
never you know the only time that serves
a purpose is when it's funny that's it
that's the only part that's not true yes
it is the only time I can think when
you're Aries energy is a positive is
when you're so hungry I don't want to be
around you because you're so miserable
it's so nasty that you can cook
something within five seconds to feed
yourself that is the only time your
tornado energy is a positive I have
other examples they seem to be escaping
me at the moment but I guess I'll
concede this argument do you know how
many times we like put something
together or build something you read
none of the directions you start doing
it suggestions you never ever ever learn
your lesson and just like try and do it
correctly it's not I don't think you
need to go by every rule in the world I
think you can sometimes just do things
rules aren't always bad sometimes rules
are also not always good they're not
always good sometimes
they prevent creativity and spreading
your butterfly wings that's fine when
the creativity is like contained in a
manner that makes any agent and get
contained you can't put creativity in a
tupperware you got to let it go so that
went well
we're going now
well you got weather shaming don't even
get me started on whether she whatever
you say I'm gonna agree with you just
because you decided to grow up in the
[ __ ] tundra doesn't mean that people
who live in less cold or extreme
climates are unable to feel cold or want
to put on a sweater or the entire city
of Los Angeles is somehow laughed at if
someone wants to put on any sort of
outer garments hat don't even get me
started just cuz you grew up in
Wisconsin or wherever the [ __ ] where
you're just miserable [ __ ] miserable
all winter long yes it's so cold that
when someone from LA says hmm
it was 50 today I put on a sweater you
feel the need to just like go after
their throat because they are not
allowed to feel cold
oh they're much warmer than I am so
therefore they cannot be cold that's not
true at all everything is relative okay
I didn't as much as I want to fault you
for growing up in the freezing place
that you grew up in I can't
which means you also can't fault me for
growing up where I grew up okay I didn't
choose it I was raised here okay I was
raised in a place where 40 is [ __ ]
freezing okay whereas you might be
raised in a place where 40 is the most
beautiful day of the year that sucks for
you and it's great for me but that
doesn't make it so I can't be cold and
put on a sweater when it's 40 degrees
don't you [ __ ] laugh at me when I say
I'm cold
oh yeah I'm cold I'm cold I'm cold
I only ever make fun of people that say
that they're cold when they know that
they're going to a snowy location and
bring like a jean jacket that's
different that's not whether that's
being ill-prepared that's being
ill-prepared I will make fun of someone
for complaining that they're cold when
they are not prepared for cold weather
know people from LA be like I'm cold and
it's a beautiful Julianne will say it
like in a vlog oh we're you know we're
gonna bring the dogs inside
cold outside and everyone's like I'm
standing in 23 feet of snow you don't
know what cold is all my limbs are
currently being frostbitten you say
you're cold you know like why are you
why are you subjecting yourself to that
why is that why is a point of pride that
you're freezing your ass off every day
oh I'm literally my whole house is
literally snowed in i live in a snow
globe great I don't care that's that's
your life I'm living in LA or sometimes
it can be a little chilly and I want to
put on a [ __ ] sweater and not get
laughed at for it don't even get me
started
look how angry I am at this all right I
think we're done with that one okay
thank you thank you good man good man
thank you
I wish you folded these hmm buying bed
sized blankets to use in living room
throws here comes a positive this is a
life hack that I learned from just going
to Target and using my brain so you know
how they sell throws in stores and even
if they say oversized throw like you
know for your living room for when
you're just on the couch they are never
as big as you want them to be they just
are not you know what I mean
so what I started doing is you go to a
bedding store bed that's beyond target
wherever you feel like you want to buy
some bedding and you know those like
where your flat sheet is and between
your comforter and your flat sheets
sometimes they sell a blanket that's
like fleece or other materials just
coziness that is queen sized or
king-sized by that and use that as your
living room blanket it is the most
underrated life hack ever when did we
start doing that well I think when I
started buying those blankets like in
Big Bear cuz we were no blanket yeah and
the only thing they had was like a
queen-size row
yeah or blanket and I was like this is
actually fantastic because it's big
enough for two people to sit under or
you and several dogs and so now at this
point we have like four king-sized
blankets downstairs and it is just the
best thing I'll cause even my brother's
like six five when he comes over if you
think I'm gonna give him a living room
throw your [ __ ] nuts it'll never
cover his whole body you give him a
king-size blanket to sit under on the
couch life changed
life better it's an underrated house
hack that I feel like other people don't
use because maybe they make the throws
more decorative or something that suits
your aesthetic fine have a couple of
them but I'm not gonna sit under them
because it's not gonna keep me warm and
it's not gonna cover my feet and I don't
want it you know this this rant here is
reminding me of when I was a kid I'll be
at my dad's house and in the living room
we had a bunch of like really cozy
really [ __ ] tiny blankets that when
you're called yes I can be cold I grew
up in LA I'm allowed to be cold when
you're cold you have to like tuck your
knees in and like really scrunch into a
ball for it to cover you yeah but I
guess I like I love those blankets right
my stepmom would buy the softest
blankets and I love them they're super
soft they're just small they're so small
yeah and so I don't know when we started
doing it but we have these huge ass like
fleece blankets downstairs in the living
room so anytime we want to cozy up it's
just like this massive you're just
covered in one yeah it's amazing it's
the best you read one more okay okay go
for it
please read it wait Julian just read it
no this is a trial read it yeah read
that's part of the game don't even get
me started on you and your segues and
how you don't fold these read the people
don't use post mates insert segue oh you
don't want to steal this one don't even
get me started on people you don't you
just post it post minutes what are you
doing going to the store for one thing
or going through a drive-thru or going
to Tripoli you know you read that listen
what you guys got to do is you got it
download the post mates out okay and any
day of the year 24 hours a day there are
options okay in your area for post mates
to deliver some delicious food some
supplies from the market for some
ingredients to cook with whatever it may
be some soap deodorant nobody's judging
especially not post mates they'll
deliver it right to your door it is such
a great app okay use code generally and
get a hundred dollars of free delivery
credit for the first seven days when you
you wouldn't use that code so check that
out use that code they also recently
sponsor the twist stream so shouts
outpost mates but this is literally a
service it is as it is as integrated in
our lives as any sponsor we've ever had
we use post mates all
the time there is always times where you
get too busy with work family whatever
it is you just don't have time to run to
the store or run to the restaurant and
pick up food okay post mates does it for
you get all the post mates app they
deliver food for you I mean it is so
seamless you see them on the map they
can call you text you it is a really
really pain-free process and you know
what if you if you need to like just
knock it out of your pajamas one day
just use postman's okay and then you
don't have to best it's amazing
what I'm just mad at you what don't even
get me started well something that you
can't post mate is farmers dog it is
whole delicious ingredients that your
dogs love but specifically made for your
dogs so basically the farmers dog is a
service where you log on to their
website the farmers dog coms last-gen
and Julien you fell out a brief
questionnaire about your pet what they
like to eat how big they are what their
eating habits are there eating schedules
and you fill out a bunch of questions
and so farmers are takes that
information formulates a meal plan and
sends you customized meals prepackaged
in these wonderfully convenient pouches
to where you freeze all of them except
for a couple you came in the fridge then
when your dog is ready to eat you just
cut open the pouch put a little nibble
and they're eating it is the most
convenient thing ever you know you're
feeding your dogs real whole ingredients
and their food not fillers not processed
nonsense no nonsense no artificial
nonsense like you're feeding your dogs
what you'd want to eat right they want
to eat just what you want to eat it's
whole food human grade ingredients check
it out the farmer's dog calm slash
energy and our dogs lose their minds for
it every single night in morning they
just lose their tiny minds because it is
really just good food for your dog so
check it out
the farmer's dog calm /gen and julienne
50% off your first two weeks of using
the farmers dog thank you sponsors any
sponsors ready you're a troll or
okay don't even get me started on how
piece learned how to grab food out of
the pantry peach decided that one day if
we don't like actually lock the pantry
she nozzles her tiny little nose in
between the doors opens it and and
there's like a lower shelf where we keep
some of our food we keep like some chips
we keep like our canned food and just
some random stuff like our pasta it's
most of the chips it's mostly the chips
so there's like a lower shelf where
she's tall enough to get up to so we've
been finding these bags of chips like
scattered throughout the house and we're
like holy [ __ ] she's literally learned
how to go into the pantry or in trouble
take our chips like just help herself to
a snack like a [ __ ] people
listen don't even get me started
no you don't even get me started because
if I had pulled that you know what I
would say this is a good thing because I
personally whenever I go to the pantry I
close the doors after I'm done with it
right okay I think it's good practice
for if ever we get a rescue Greyhound
which I'm sure we'd love to get some day
and for them or for anything else in the
future when you're done with the food
you close those doors for bugs or god
forbid a raccoon or something came to
close the door close off the food I'm
glad that she learned how to get those
chips off there because it will teach
you to stop leaving doors open and food
where people and little things can grab
food don't get me started it's a good
thing yes this one was and if we get a
big dog you're in for a world of hurt
Julian you can't be mad at her the food
was there ready for her to grab what if
you left the pantry open I don't leave
the pantry open damn it
okay that's just like I don't leave the
refrigerator I leave that sometimes they
do sometimes it's not true all right you
know what that one that one it's okay
sometimes you just gotta yeah sometimes
you got to admit defeat
I don't like this one okay skip it all
right I want to gift this one to you
because this didn't apply to me when
your parent doesn't understand you can't
pause an online game oh there were no
started when I'll even get me started
mom specifically mom I'm growing up all
right
I'm playing Halo with my friends that
we're playing xbox live you know talking
all sorts of [ __ ] to each other on our
little stupid headsets you can't walk in
the garage and say hey I need you to
pause your game so you can do your
laundry no mom there needs to be some
sort of humane order to this
I can't pause it online game because
that would be pausing the game for 15
other people who are also playing with
you don't have to do stupid like I
understand this as an adult but no one
is telling me to pause my online this is
something that to this day my mom
probably doesn't understand like if we
if she comes over to my house and right
and I'm playing in pub G or seizure
whatever she comes in is I need you to
pause that game not that she can really
tell me that cuz I'm a [ __ ] adult I
don't want to pause the game anymore
but she's still like that as a concept
that I think she still doesn't
understand and that's that's just how
it's like she's never understood it she
just thinks that oh you don't want a
posit no I can't deposit
I either concede and just leave my
character afk and die or you wait til
the end like a normal person do your
laundry after the game is over and then
you come back and start you know owning
when you're back when you're done but
don't tell you to pause the game you
couldn't tell your mom you couldn't
explain that to your mom well I did but
she just thinks it's like I remember
yelling like I can't pause the game but
her thinking like I'm just making
excuses so I can keep playing mmm well I
wonder why you you're an Aries full of
excuses my mom's an Aries too it's a
recipe for disaster
well you know I was also I've also
played many video games at many friend's
house growing up and all of their
parents seem to have the same problem
that mine did because they understand
video games as like a game that you can
pause they don't understand that the
complaint online with other people
can't pause it other people are
depending on me right now yeah
I can't I'm playing with other other
people it's like it's like if you played
football and your mom comes in and says
hey I need you to pause this game what
do I tell all 20 other people in the
field to just like positive they're
doing no this is a group activity didn't
apply to me the only game somewhere
around when I was a kid we're single
player or stuff like that P Gees yeah
we're like Nintendo 64 where you can
pause I don't even get me started
I'm thankful though are you gonna play
Halo when it comes out yeah I'm so
excited to play Halo of DC this one's
also for you don't even started on
businesses in 2019 that are cache slash
check only the reason why I said this
one is also for Jillian's because every
what Monday Tuesday Thursday Monday
Monday he rolls with his coach in
jujitsu private and he's only takes a
check I don't understand it
like venmo is so easy to download and
I've even told him about that more I've
been like I like her you only ordered
checks to pay your coach and you have a
book of checks to only write a check to
my coach for jujitsu and it's like so
silly and that's not even like the worst
like that's you know I think he's he's
like what's this venmo is this safe you
know I think it's like it's a fair you
know hesitation but at the same time I
always think like I'm right every time I
write the check I can't believe I'm
writing a [ __ ] check like I just
can't believe I'm writing a check in
today's day and age but are you worse
than that like cuz that's not
necessarily a business right that's just
one person who I so I think about all
the nail salons that I go to and then
they only accept tips and cash which
used to be the status quo for like a
restaurant you would leave cash on the
table for your waitress yes but imagine
if all restaurants just decided nah man
it's way too risky to let people tip in
on their card or whatever
everything would be a [ __ ] show you you
have 18 people line longs at every ATM
everywhere
yeah also you have people walking around
now
especially with the new Apple
announcement like Apple pay is getting
sleeker and more convenient than ever
most people just have their phones if
they even have a credit card that's
debatable but say say someone was like
paying it for everything with their
phone they literally can't get to an ATM
with it and they can't tip it cash
because it's just our phone like come on
dude wake up get one of those little
readers the little scrapes I don't even
carry my like debit card with me to go
get cash i I know it's not doing that
because like I put all of my expenses on
to one card which is a credit card right
yeah but then like I used to only use my
debit card all the time for everything
because I was like you know super
careful with my money one wanted to
never ever ever spend somebody didn't
have but I also wasn't building any
credit yeah I've switched over to a
different type of system but I don't
because I'm not a person that goes and
gets cash all the time I don't carry my
debit card anymore because it just makes
my accounting more difficult to put
things on different cards ya know so I
think a lot of people are in that same
ya iteration so I stopped carrying my
debit card
so like even from out in the world and
someone's like you know tip in cash or
whatever I'm like [ __ ] Julian do you
have any cash because sometimes Julian
is cash in his car whatever I'd never
have any cash I never have any cash yeah
I try to keep emergency stashes in my
car in my wallet but like like we like
to go to those little fruit stands and
just buy some fruit and they are owned
like cash only yeah like I imagine it
wouldn't be too difficult for them to
set up one of those little square
readers well just take a venmo to things
on set to things that say the fruit
cards I understand why businesses are
cash only
I'm just saying I would maybe consider
your future I would say if there is an
exception to this rule
it's like street meat and fruit cart
yeah yeah like those guys there it's an
old-school thing that's fine if you're
if you if you're going out of the house
with any shadow of any small chance that
you're gonna use that service you know
you're gonna bring cash right how much
their business would grow if they also
offered a way for you to just bend mow
or use a little square one thing I will
say
this would explode those people that are
running in the park they are not running
with a bunch of cash in their pocket who
the hell goes for a jog with a bunch of
cash in their pocket I I agree I think
it would behoove all these small
business owners to have any sort of
little chip or card reader I do want to
say though to be fair okay
then mo on certain credit cards takes a
fee its square and so on all purchases
makes a fat [ __ ] fee and PayPal
unless it's for a family your friend
takes a fee so I don't want to diminish
you know that effect of using some some
sort of service or because I know for a
lot of people like those fees add up and
they're like this isn't it worth it
right so I get that I know what PayPal
but isn't there a way for it so that the
user the one that's buying the service
or paying for the whatever is paying the
fee because I think that there's plenty
of people that are okay paying an extra
fee on top of whatever for the
convenience of not having cash yes well
I think I think with venmo it's like
that right so if I wanted to venmo you
with using a certain credit card
it would let me know while I was picking
that credit card that it's gonna take a
certain fee from my purchase not from
the the recipient with square it's
different Square takes just like a
across-the-board fee from any merchant
who's accepting payment using Square and
they've been like that for a little time
and I think that's really kind of like
me a lot of people not want to use
square because of that fee because it
really is not a tiny fee and it adds up
and this and that but I also know that
like it becomes kind of confusing for
tax purposes right like if you if you're
using venmo right and you're paying
someone the event Moe for like say a
haircut at the end of the year you have
to go through and like maybe that looks
wrong in the eyes of the IRS or whatever
if it's like a family or friend type of
payment through an app like that I don't
know nothing
not that claiming cash was pretty
difficult as well I don't know whatever
I but I do think at the heart of the
argument it is funny that your coach and
probably so many other people and
services still only take a check or cash
when they could just as easily set up
yeah that mom true
okay don't even don't even get Beast
on pineapple on pizza delicious oh you
silly boy
it's really good it's not really good
it's not really good you're wrong it's
not good your taste buds deceive you
you're lying your body's like because I
like a complex flavor Pro wow I'm so
blown away your flavor profile you put
it on mute so you relax
have you ever had grilled pineapple it's
gross it's delicious it's gross I need
my pineapple to be fresh and juicy and
Chris plantains man a little less gross
not not my favorite stuff so it sounds
like you're just against warm fruit yeah
why would I want one thing it's cool
it's good I'm supposed to be room
temperature cold
I don't want warm fruit that's insane
that's insanity no it's where nature
does fruit get war grilled watermelon is
that a thing
there's no cruising jumping you eat
watermelon you take it out of where it's
growing and you take a bite of it that's
how it's meant to be eaten I don't know
if watermelons bro the jungle where do I
describe not a jungle
that's not my plate I don't like warm
fruit that's actually thank you your
problem that's the root of my problem
well I think I think fruit is I'm all
for like mixing like the cranberry salad
you made with like olive oil and
cranberry it's literally warm fruit okay
but can I just finish here by the time
it's on my plate nothing's warm you cook
it sure but by the time is on my plate
I'm my point is my point is high before
you feel my point a small hot fruit my
point is I'm okay with having savory and
sweet flavors mixed especially when it
comes to fruit and dishes something
about pineapple being cooked in any
capacity just grosses me the [ __ ] out
pineapple upside-down cake I don't know
what that is and frankly I don't care to
know what about those cupcakes with the
pineapple on him those are cooked what
what cupcakes are the pineapple on them
we had those remember Kat gave us a
bunch of cupcakes with pineapple on him
it was cooked the memory invades me I
just what about like a cake with
I was very in it cooked I'm saying
specifically pineapple is gross when
it's cooked just so revolting and soft
Oh
like why dude it's such a great person
why you're ranting about how you don't
like hot fruit and it belongs to colder
I'm actually I'm actually no you're not
allowed to eat pies anymore Wow I'm
zeroing in on pineapple not fruit I
never said warm fruit is gross well
actually I did they yelled that mainly
pineapple is disgusting I just think any
warm pineapple should be banned but you
know if you like pineapple on your pizza
that's fine just post me I'm sorry
you're so wrong it's one of the most
passionate it's one of the most like
passionate debated subjects ever okay go
ahead don't even get me started this is
one that kind of gone either way if I
picked it are you on electric scooters
you hate those things I don't like to go
fast I don't like to go fast
I don't like electric scooters we saw
two kids in the park the other day both
on one they were ready to either kill
themselves or kill somebody else both
probably they were gonna take a spill or
there's no other no there was no other
outcome so here in Los Angeles as well
as many other cities you can sort of
rent through an app a little electric
scooter and they have birds there I get
all of the convenience and like renting
something and then being able to leave
it somewhere like I think the idea is
super rad yeah I just don't know who was
like yeah electric scooters they go so
fast
people ride them wherever the [ __ ] not
even in places where it says don't ride
those [ __ ] things here okay it's an
it's a nuisance to children and dogs and
people Clark is robbed that kids
literally needed surgery on his elbow
cuz he [ __ ] tumbled off one he is no
no no that's
dangerous okay and we know one person
that got hurt it's only gonna get worse
from here you don't have to wear a
helmet shroud did not use a bird only
line to her shoulder
this is electrics this says electrics
hold up hold up he bought he has an
electric argument okay but no you can't
just you can't just mention an example
okay let me just dispute that one little
micro argument okay Shroud is different
because he bought a supercharged
electric scooter that goes like 50 or 60
okay but not the type we're talking
about here I'm talking about the lives
of the birds behind it but I'm talking
about all electric scooters they're not
a problem they just aren't there yet
okay the law hasn't caught up yet nobody
knows where you're supposed to ride them
or where you can't ride them right on
the [ __ ] thing it says do not ride on
sidewalk yet what you're supposed to
ride it in the middle of the street it's
confused exactly it is a big tosser well
it's not dangerous I don't want to take
one I don't like going fast I would
rather walk thank you very much I would
quite literally not rather walk
I would rather scoot very fast good and
get to where I'm going and get hit by a
car I have never in my life on that on a
scooter gotten hit by a car only on my
bike have I gotten hit by a car the car
was parked and it was my fault yeah but
you want a helmet on did I yeah you
don't have to wear how much to wear want
to don't ride on one of those things no
it's so dangerous
yeah it is dangerous but it's at your
own risk well I think people the other
day I had to run errands on before ok no
it's not you're don't even get me
started on you getting started
ok follow we'll get started at you dog
you good your turn
don't even get me started on people
going crazy over enough for every
Netflix original that's the TV right
there so I came up with a theory that
whenever things come out on Netflix
people generally sort of like lose their
[ __ ] minds over [ __ ] because they
have a subscription to Netflix
and its new so they watch it and they
think it's amazing and then I also feel
like I whenever someone tells me like oh
you got to see this movie or oh you got
to see this thing like unless it's like
a universal overwhelming sort of like I
don't I don't watch a lot of movies in
the first place yeah mainly because of
this reason there's always somebody
telling me it's so [ __ ] good dude
it's so good you got to [ __ ] watch it
I loved it it's so [ __ ] good and then
I watch it and I'm disappointed and now
I'm angry at my friend for hyping that
[ __ ] up or I'm angry at that person
online that was ranting and raving about
it like yeah sure it's okay but I feel
like there's a phenomena where people
just have a Netflix subscription so
anything new they think is the best
[ __ ] thing that's ever came out and I
just disagree
well because it's high production it's
free it's usually starring someone
pretty important and so they're usually
well or not but they're used to paying
for a content like that in the theater
or on demand or something so the fact
that you're getting it for free and your
net box dashboard Netflix dashboard is
is like oh my god this is free it's
incredible but it's not most of it's
just okay I think people are being
clouded by the fact that it's free on
Netflix so they can't adequately like
judge that's what I'm saying what it is
like I don't like great I think it's
just okay a lot of this [ __ ] that comes
out of Netflix I agree it's not you
don't even get me started but I agree
with you I wouldn't give an example okay
that we went through recently is love
death and robots again I mean all we I
mean first of all I want to say I
enjoyed it it was really well done the
animation absolutely blew my [ __ ]
mind
yeah like some some of the episodes were
really cool like very stylistic nice
cool stories yeah cool show idea but
people really made it sound like it was
the [ __ ] best thing since sliced
bread
yeah the animated versions lack
mirror-black meter times two but
animated but in small form content it's
the first of its kind everyone just like
oh my god it's amazing and like it was
great but it's like there's no need to
hype it up that much because it truly
wasn't that good it was good it was
really good but it wasn't as good as
people were describing it I was
acting to be like I was expecting after
I watch it was very not safe for ya but
I was expecting how I felt when I
watched black mirror for the first time
when you're just like a little bit mind
[ __ ] yeah I didn't get like that it
made me think it was cool but yeah
that's how I felt when people were
hyping up pen15
they were like oh my god it's so
nostalgic like it's so good it's so
funny and like the first couple episodes
I was like yeah I get it and it's a
little nostalgic but I also this was not
my experience whatsoever I you know not
really 100% relating but I like the
nostalgia I like the idea of adult
characters playing middle schoolers it's
funny but then it just completely lost
its [ __ ] charm and I just didn't
[ __ ] liked it and I was like why are
people hyping the [ __ ] out of this yeah
the joke is tired and old and some of it
was just like so [ __ ] unnecessary so
[ __ ] unnecessary and I shut it off
and I was like that's a [ __ ] enough
of that goodbye she started you could
have done it for two seconds but no yet
it didn't make an entire episode about
the weirdest grossest masturbation [ __ ]
that I was relating to that being like
yes dude what the [ __ ] I was all set and
I shut it off and I said [ __ ] you
Twitter that's enough that's the last
time I'm listening you saying this thing
on Netflix is so [ __ ] good [ __ ] off
shut up I'm done I was eating dinner
yeah those sometimes I just like to like
have a little escape right I just want
to watch something
yeah and relax and be able to eat a meal
with it like how you feel at the office
are there ever really points in the
office where you're like oh man I really
got to shut off this show because I
can't watch it like I just want like a
nice relaxing show to watch ya know I
hear you you know
yeah or if there's [ __ ] graphic
content at least give me a water today
don't eat your food to this maybe
instead of the are you still watching
feature we can get a don't eat any food
to this feature that would be way more
helpful I'll talk to my guy at Netflix
thank you
they drinking outside as an adult don't
get me started
I don't feel passionate about this one
do you want to take it no just that I
can't do it anymore I get way too
oh so don't even get me started on yeah
well it this way in my life I feel like
if I'm just laying outside for long
enough I get really tired you know just
like being outside I get tired add
alcohol in there and it's just an app
city they drinking when you were a young
man
easy to do easy to do it anymore weekday
weddings Oh yikes
don't even get me started
Oh yikes on making your wedding during
the week whose idea was that
well no time out there's plenty reasons
why people have weekday weddings saves
them a butt ton of money I think it's
totally appropriate and fine if it's
small and local and like everyone that
is coming is around you know like do
your thing but if it's not small and
it's not low you make it people traveler
video Thursday evening wedding when
everyone else has to work oh well you're
actively preventing this person from
making money off work and if they decide
that maybe they're in a situation with
their job or whatever where they can't
do that you're an [ __ ] because you
didn't come to my wedding
sometimes yeah exactly sometimes people
work years and years and years just to
add one vacation day to their allotted
vacation days and you're you're asking
for them to take those for your wedding
because you want to save some money or
whatever just I don't get it I just
don't I don't even get me started I
think it's a lot you got me started well
and it's not like oh we're just getting
married and then we're gonna have a
dinner I'm talking him like full-on
ceremony
Thursday morning and then the receptions
Thursday night and then you're mad when
people leave your wedding early or don't
want to like party and have a great time
because they're also have a pitch
meeting at work tomorrow work the next
day they have a pitch meeting have a
pitch meeting the head honcho is gonna
be there mm-hmm
watching the pitch meeting right oh
don't even get me started on people
snapchatting the entire concert that
they go to shouldn't gotta start out is
not a concert snapchat is not a concert
is not a concert I just I I get why
people go to concerts and film things on
their phone I get it I think it's cool
for a little bit because then you get to
have that memory and yeah it's for you
yeah and I understand why people want
you know the more aggressive people want
to be in the front they want to get all
the the best shots of this person live
and you know if anything ever happened
you'd have all this footage of it be
cool yeah but like I don't I don't fully
I'm not completely on board with the
standing at a concert and sort of just
watching it through your phone yeah
that's so weird and people just leave it
rolling like I I agree with you I get
like maybe it's your favorite song in
the set and you wanted to record a clip
of it so you can remove it or even like
a picture or something yeah the people
who just leave it rolling and they're
like also like seems to not really being
joining themselves it's almost like
they're pirating a movie they're just
like what's the point
well I get some of it so say you were at
a concert and you know you're the
biggest fan like you want to remember
this and where you were standing the
whole thing for forever I totally get it
I do feel like you're missing some of
the concert by constantly recording it
fine whatever
but I do get the thrill of rewatching it
on your phone yeah or like sharing a
little bit of it or whatever what I
don't understand is how you went from
having all of those positive things for
yourself and then putting the entire
thing on [ __ ] snapchat so where your
story is like 10 minutes long I've just
like really really bad to start a
concert audio through an iPhone or even
worse an Android don't get it it's
really hard to watch them too I'm not
like Oh sick dude those [ __ ] dope I'm
like this is how it looks this is how it
sounds like I'm watching someone's story
who required a whole concert because I'm
just skipping every single like oh like
many other things I feel like people
snapchat or Instagram story that they're
at a concert because it's them sharing
that they're at a concert yeah it's like
it's the social media you want to show
people what you're up to right so I I
get I get a little bit of that and then
I feel like everyone has sort of a line
where
that's over and that's completely across
that line it's cool you went to the
concert but that's it I'm happy for you
yeah I'm happy that you have front row
but it's all for you it's also just
allowed like when you watch your
Instagram say you like Instagram sorry
or snapchat for an entire day and at the
end of the day you're like I want to
watch my story see like what the day was
usually when you make a long story
something cool happened or you were
excited about something or whatever and
you never really watch it you're like
god this is miserable to watch because
if you do then you wouldn't have done it
because a concert on snapchat is so loud
and so bad to listen to and so not even
close to what it's like to be there
what's the point
well lucky for us it's almost time for
Coachella so it's time to watch
everyone's story like live podcasts on
the main stage at Coachella imagine that
would beat my health I know I still like
after all these years I still have no
desire to go to Coachella or other large
music festivals I get why people love
them and there's some people that would
you know spend every last penny that
they have and they can't wait to save
like I get it you know yeah it's just
not for me
I just don't absolutely absolutely would
retweet that but I mean being in that
crowd of people and like going through
just anxiety City yeah it's like even if
I didn't feel like that about being in
crowds of people I'm just yeah I don't
know how I appreciate music
I appreciate you live music but on that
scale like really makes me it's too much
but I like watching Coachella
you know on TV well after they started
televising it yeah well they live stream
on YouTube love you live the Coachella
live streams are really really cool yeah
cuz they're not shot on an iPhone in the
crowd oh damn get him me t yeah I do
like live music but not that that type
of venues speaking of live music let's
let benefit now do our portion of the
show where we shot someone cool out that
we found their content to be cool this
week what's the name of this segment
let's think of a name Jake army right on
time what should what should be the name
of this little anyway it's like
divergent of Philips fill up different
goes today an awesome sort of but Jenna
has one go wait I don't have one yeah
you said you were gonna do one oh I like
Dylan's new song Dillon Francis how's
the new song they're really new song is
really good it's really good it's called
change your mind that's probably my
favorite thing this week
it's a that's a really well that and
Logie sent me a bunch of plants and I
can't even
they sent me a [ __ ] philodendron pink
princess that's not content on the
Internet I had around I literally
haven't wrap my head around it it's a
very rare plant well it's just it's not
that it's so unbelievably rare it's just
so difficult to get because everyone
wants them and they sent me one yeah
anyways your turn my favorite piece of
content that I found on the internet
this week comes from a creator that I've
been falling for a long time binging
with babish he was literally tearing up
dude he created a show called being with
babish right and the first episode of
the show he sets out to help out a fan
of the show who maybe had fallen on some
hard times and oh my god I cannot
recommend it enough it is just like so
tasteful and genuine and well done and
Andrew binging with babish is such a
creative person you can tell and how he
makes his videos that you could you
could just like feel like every bit of
love that went in the episode and they
like flew down Orlando to help out this
guy and it's just like everything about
it it's just like such a great piece of
content I loved it I can't wait til the
next episode I love seeing people who
are super creative but maybe have found
themselves in a little bit of a box
branch out into something different so
for him he branched away from his
cooking videos to make this series
called being with babish and I just like
a plot that so much because it you know
it clearly is like we're working for him
and he made some great [ __ ] so we'll
link those two things below but yeah
those are our favorite things on the
Internet yeah Kermit he like knows when
the podcast is over he starts crying I
know they know the timing of the podcast
and the stream like when we say goodbye
to our friends
they start flipping out they start
flipping out and they know it's time to
go anyway guys thank you for tuning in
to another podcast you love you all very
much hope you have a wonderful weekend
we'll be back here with another episode
next week have a good one bye
[Music]